[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBBAIAH VENKATA:
Welcome, everyone.
Good afternoon.
What a great event.
Thank you for being here.
Let's get started.
I want to tell a
story, a small story.
I don't think, actually,
it's a real story.
I don't think many of
you heard about it.
Anyone can recognize
this painting?
Anyone?
This is one of the great
paintings called The Concert.
I love art.
Basically, I go to a lot of
museums around the world.
Like Rembrandt and Vermeer.
This is Vermeer's
The Concert painting.
This is one of the most
expensive paintings
of worth $200 million.
And Vermeer is a
very great artist.
We are still learning about him.
He's a 17th century artist.
If you go search
for Tim's Vermeer,
there's a great
documentary about it.
He invented a new type of
art called optical using
optical equipment to do art.
So we know very less about him.
Like only 34 paintings have
ever been attributed to him.
And one of these is actually--
got stolen, by the way.
This painting was in Boston's
Isabella Stewart Museum.
Roughly about 27 years
ago, on March 18, 1990
in the early morning
days, the morning hours,
two people came in disguised
as police officers, cops.
They stole the identity.
They breached all
the security stuff,
stole 13 paintings from
the art museum on that day.
And that is one of the
world's greatest thefts ever,
a single theft ever, which is
roughly attributable to $500
million of theft.
You can go to Wikipedia
and learn about it.
After that 1990
theft of museums,
the security around the museums
have dramatically changed.
This is the great museums
of artwork, I think.
So I want to connect the dots,
actually, as we progress,
like why this is the case.
If you look at this, this
is the Metropolitan Museum
of Art in New York.
This is one of
the great museums.
I think you should
go and visit it.
Same thing.
Google data centers.
We consider all our
data centers hosting
the great artworks of
our customers, your data,
your applications,
and everything
is we want to make sure that
this is the art of yours.
We want precious things.
We want to treasure it.
So all the things that
we wanted to secure,
whatever the museums are
doing around the world--
by the way, since 1990,
there is no many thefts
have actually gone down.
Same thing in data centers.
If you look at the
prediction for Gartner,
in 2020, the number of theft
or security breaches in data
centers will go down by 60%.
I strongly believe this is true.
I'll tell you the
reasons for it.
Number one is Google,
especially Google,
is going to hire great
talent for security experts
around the globe.
We keep them happy.
We recruit them.
And we make sure that we
solve the great problems.
And number two, the second
reason why this is true,
this will be true in 2020, is
when one customer's security
are breached for some
reason, any reason,
immediately, within
a few days, we
are going to fix the same issue
for all the customers, all
the hundreds and
thousands of customers.
This is not possible in
the private data centers.
It's very difficult because
you have to know the community.
You have to know what
the vulnerabilities are.
You have to get the
right concerting people
to get it patched
with and roll it out.
It's very, very hard.
Whereas if you have
thousands of customers,
you're always upgrading
your security principles,
tools, practices.
I think the security will
be super good in public data
centers going forward.
There's no question about it.
With that, I would like to
start the talk with three
main things, actually,
we want to cover.
Number one, secure VPC.
So Google has a virtual
private cloud networking.
And what are the tools we're
offering for the security site?
Next, Palo Alto
Network's Jigar is
going to give a demo on using
our tools to build Palo Alto's
great application, third party
applications into Google Cloud.
The last, Prajakta
and Michelle are going
to talk about security edge.
Michelle is from Cloudflare.
She's going to talk about
how Cloudflare partnered
with Google around
the globe to protect
from all kinds of attacks.
I'm Subbaiah Vekanta.
I'm director of
Google Networking.
I'm going to talk
about secure VPC.
Let's step back a minute and
see where the Google footprints,
globally, is.
So you can see from this diagram
that we are in four regions
so far--
US East, US West,
Asia, and Europe.
And this year, by
end of this year,
we will be in many more regions.
We'll be in Singapore, India,
Australia, South America,
a couple more in Asia,
one more in US East Coast.
And all the numbers
you see in those things
are the zones within each
region, how many zones we'll
have in each region.
The footprint is global.
All of these are connected
with Google's amazing backbone
network.
And you'll get a great quality
of service, bandwidth, latency.
Everything we do, you get it.
So same backbone will be used
for Google Search, Google Maps,
YouTube, and everything.
Next, zooming into only
networking-specific things,
what do we offer in
networking toolkit today?
Number one, we offer fundamental
networking features, like VPC,
networks, regional
subnetworks, routing tables,
firewall tables, all kinds
of cross-product networking
we're going to introduce.
We did last yesterday a
great talk over at XPN.
We're going to introduce a
couple more new features.
This will be great.
I will be introducing four
new features in this talk.
The second one is control.
Control is about
how you actually
manage and make
sure that you have
control over your resources
that you have in Google Cloud.
That includes IAM permissions,
all kinds of monitoring,
alerting, dashboards,
visualization, as well
as Stackdriver, basically
the company we bought,
can provide most
of those things.
Third is the services.
In networking alone,
we continuously
offer some value-added
services to customers.
That includes load
balancing as a service.
Load balancing has many flavors.
We have L3 load balancers.
We have L7 load balancers.
And we introduce internal
L3 load balancers--
[? Jade-- ?] this year.
Similarly, we have
CDN as a service.
We have DNS as a service.
These are the new networking
services we keep offering.
And you will see many
more in the coming months.
The last, but not the
least is a hybrid cloud.
We believe that
big and [AUDIO OUT]
definitely be in
multiple data centers,
like private cloud
and public cloud.
So we offer VPN as a service,
IPSec VPNs as a service,
cloud router doing
BGP as a service.
And we do interconnect,
private interconnect, public
interconnect to Google.
All of these will
conclude that we
have all the necessary and
sufficient functionality
and features for you to migrate
to Google Cloud, either 100%
workloads or partial workloads.
Now let's zoom in to specific
control features, like IAM.
In this year alone, we
actually enhanced IAM
so much that there
is a specific talk,
actually, later today
and tomorrow about IAM
best practices.
Let me give a small glimpse
about what IAM has to offer.
The new thing we
did this year was we
talked through how we
can organize resources
in such a way that
we want to think
big for the big enterprises.
So let's say that you have
a big, huge organizations
and then all these
sort of Home Depot
and all these
enterprises coming in.
We wanted to create a node
called Organization node.
Inside the Organization node,
you can divide, let's say,
engineering department, finance
department, and HR department.
All of these are different
folders you can create.
Folders are a very
flexible way to organize.
You can organize your
enterprises differently.
Let's say, you can
organize them by partners
or the companies you bought.
Let's say, a company
buys another company.
You can bring that as
another folder there.
And then within the
folder, you have Projects.
Projects sees the entity
that we had for a long time.
All the billing, all
the quota enforcement,
all kinds of attribution has to
happen in the Projects level.
So usually, Project
can be, let's say,
divided as test project
or development project.
Or you can say, Project
can be microservices.
For example, Spotify gives
each microservice a project.
Between the project,
you can bring up
any Resources you want,
either networking resources,
compute resources,
or storage resources,
as you can see in the diagram.
Now, coming to the
policies, what are the IAM
features that we offer?
Just let me give a simple,
brief description about IAM,
how we think about IAM.
There's just who.
Who is IAM?
Who here means, actually,
the identities and roles.
And what?
What are the tools you have?
What are the policies
that can apply to where,
to where are the resources
that we just saw?
In other words, Google
offers two main things
for the identities and roles.
If you go look inside
our [INAUDIBLE] console,
you will see you can use
Google Groups as identities.
You can use your email
address as identities.
And we introduced something
called Service Account.
Service accounts is-- let's say,
you downloaded a third party
application.
You don't want to trust
that, because maybe it's
hundreds and thousands
of lines of code there.
You don't know what that
particular application
is doing.
You can attach an identity to
that particular third party
code.
That's what a
service account is.
And IAM policies are the verbs.
You can think of actions.
For example, you can say,
at this particular instance,
admin can have a view
permission, list permission,
add/delete permissions.
And then you can actually
add some kind of custom verbs
to it.
We do have custom
verbs, like setBacks,
setLabels are all custom verbs.
And then we have Resources
that we just saw,
like big hierarchies
of resources.
So all of these are possible.
You can mix and match
the roles and identities
and the policies of the verbs.
And then the resources,
you can mix and match.
It's because of big metrics
of clear demarcation
and authentication
you have to play with,
like who should get what
permissions in each hierarchy.
And it's very clear,
easy to remember
that the hierarchy,
if you go back,
the hierarchy is,
in the reference,
you can see that
it's inheritance.
The top most-- let's say, if
you give a instance admin,
like the org admin,
a ownership role,
he has complete control of
all the resources and all
the projects.
So there are best practices
we should actually give when
you're using IAM at Google.
Number one is grant rules
using Google Groups.
Don't use individual
email addresses.
Create a group, and then give
that particular identity,
and then give a particular
role for that identity.
Similarly, I think you
should go with something
like a used all-concept
primitives that will already
offer all kinds
of verbs, and try
to give the least common
privileges to the resources.
Don't give a very
broad privileges,
then it's very difficult
what's going on,
as what happened in the artwork.
It's a security
breach by identity.
They came with cops' identity.
And then they stole it.
And that they removed the
firewalls, that kind of thing
they did.
So the same thing will happen.
IAM is a classic dot I want to
connect back to the painting
that I just showed you.
Because of the security
breach, it most likely
will happen, because of
the wrong IAM permissions.
And then you can go over that.
And then tomorrow at 11:20,
you have a great talk
about best practices in IAM.
And we are actually
offering more features.
They'll talk about the feature.
One such feature is
custom IAM roles.
Now, IAM is done.
Let's move on to, let's say,
the perimeter security and VPC
in deep.
I don't need to repeat this.
But traditionally,
the data center,
if you go to any
third parties, they
are going to sell you
boxes and proxies.
And you have to put these
boxes in the middle layers,
like load balancers
and firewalls.
Whenever you need
to grow, you have
to grow them scale out way, but
performance is going to suffer.
You need to actually
spend a lot of capex
to buy more of these firewalls,
more of these load balancers,
right?
It's a given.
That's what, actually, all
the enterprises get money
from that.
But they become choke points.
Let me tell you a
less known secret
about this, why this is going
to fail in the very short-term.
The networking bandwidth
is increasing very rapidly.
We just saw 1 gig to 10
gig to 40 gig to 100 gig.
By 2020, lot of the
public cloud links
will be at 100 gig,
everything 100 gig.
I don't think the catch-up
of the security industry
to do a line rate deep packet
inspection, line rate IDS
and IPS, will catch
up to 100 gig.
That means you need to buy much
bigger boxes, maybe more boxes
to do 100-gig line rate
deep packet inspection.
It's not going to work.
So you have to think through
a completely different model
than removing these proxies.
So with that, I start
off with clearly
introducing four new features.
This is a slide you
should remember.
I think takeaway
slide is, we are
proud to offer distributor
firewalls, enhancement
additional firewalls
or egress firewalls.
It's in alpha right now.
We'll go to beta pretty soon.
The second feature is
VPC network sharing.
Yesterday there was a
great talk about this.
We are proud to announce a
beta of this two days ago.
Third feature is VPC peering.
It's a simple private peering.
It's great for SaaS
providers, so consumers
can access all the
producer's SaaS services.
The fourth feature is
super important for all
the third party appliances
to come to Google
and provide their virtual
appliances within Google
is multi-NIC support
for virtual machines.
It is alpha right now.
We're going to go
to beta pretty soon.
And there's one more
stuff in security, which I
don't want to talk about here--
[INAUDIBLE] gave the
presentation in this--
is we have more
application-level security
coming up called
Identity Aware Proxy.
We have custom IAM roles, and
we have data loss prevention.
There's a nice demo
in the keynote.
And then we are working more
towards content aware security
too.
So you're going to see that.
Let's focus on VPC alone in
this particular presentation.
Let's start with
a VPC topology 1.
I have five topologies
or solutions
so you can think about how
you can use these solutions.
Let's have an organization.
Think example.com
or spotify.com.
Then you wanted
the networks to be
isolated for a specific reason.
Maybe you bought a company or
there is a completely different
formula.
Let's say that engineering
department should not
want to see the quarterly
results of the sales
department.
So you want to keep the sales
department completely isolated
in a different network.
Even by mistake of the
firewall rules and policies,
no engineer should be able to
watch our sales department's
quarterly reports.
It's pure isolation.
This is one model.
So you have two
different networks
under the same organization,
two different security
admins who do support it.
And both networks are
global, by the way.
So Google's VPCs are global,
but they're isolated.
You can bring up up to
five networks in a project.
And within an organization,
you can bring up
hundreds of networks.
There is absolutely-- we don't
limit it in an organization.
If you have a project,
we'll limit to five.
But if you call the
support, we can even
increase that limit too.
Now, if you have that,
now you can say, hey,
still I wanted some specific.
Let's say, my
[? NGVP ?] should be
able to access the sales one, or
my engineering development team
should be able to access
the test department
or something like that.
Then you can punch the hole
using specific public IPs.
You can create them,
called forwarding IPs.
And you can actually
create firewall rules.
Only those particular IPs are
going to talk to each other.
And you can create firewall
rules in both networks.
That means two
different networks are
going to talk on public IPs.
And there is a second
way to do this,
is maybe because you might
think they're all public IPs,
still there's a perception that
it's going to the internet.
Actually, it's not
going to the internet.
It is going through still
the Google's backbone
network, because those IPs
are still Google public IPs.
Just to make the
things comfortable,
you can create VPN tunnels
between the two networks.
It costs a little
bit more, because you
have to bring up this virtual
IPSec VPN gateways that Google
offers and cloud router
that Google offers,
but it just gives
you the security
that everything crossing the
two networks across the regions
is more secure in IPSec tunnels.
Optimal topology number 3.
This we want to be--
we're very proud of.
We started from scratch.
This is called VPC
sharing, where you have,
as [INAUDIBLE] mentioned
yesterday, a lot of people
are trying to use Project.
I just want the project
to be by department
where they have a
complete freedom
to create their compute
and storage resources.
Networking is
completely different.
I want to have a
different department
to handle the networking stuff.
Let's create a global network
for all the departments
to attach to.
And my security team
and networking team
is to make sure that no one
stepped onto each other.
That's the request we got
from all the customers.
Hey, give us one network
where all my departments
can use that network.
And we know how to create
firewall rules in that one
network.
So we offer shared VPC.
Now, optimal topology number 4--
the same organization,
multi-NIC support.
This is fantastic.
This is a whole ecosystem
of third parties.
We are working with
so many partners.
You will see a talk and demo
from Palo Alto Networks.
If you have an organization,
again, same organization,
you have two networks.
You want to make sure that
all the VMs in one network
has to funnel
through a set of VMs
where you want to do all
kinds of security policies,
deep packet inspections, IDS,
IPS to be done in those VMs,
then use multi-NIC feature.
You can say that all
the consumer network has
to have a route to these
multi-NIC VMs in the producer
network, then you
can do, actually,
all the processing there.
It's a kind of proxying, but
you have this option available.
If you have services with all
the third party appliances,
you can tell them that please
bring it to Google Cloud.
They're happy to do it.
Optimal topology number 5--
VPC network peering.
We are very proud to offer
this as an alpha thing.
This is a game-changer, too.
This is going to
provide a value-based
versus the cost-based for
all the SaaS providers.
What that means is I am a
producer of some service
X, a SaaS service.
If a customer or consumer
comes and asks me,
hey, I wanted your service,
let's say, Spanner service
or anything you wanted.
I can bring up 10 [? to ?] VMs.
I can charge 10 VMs' worth.
They don't need to know how
many VMs I'm running for them.
It's completely hidden.
Because two different
organizations,
two different
networks are peering,
all you need to do is
having a peering agreement.
And we beautifully did
this in the UI itself.
Two different organizations,
two different networks
can peer with each other.
First, consumer or
producer has to say,
hey, I want to peer
with this organization,
this project, this network, and
then the call comes to that.
The other organization admin
has to accept in the UI,
saying that, OK, I
accept that I peer
with this other
organization network.
Boom.
Nothing, no proxies, nothing.
Behind the scenes,
everything is a magic.
We mesh all the VMs, full
mesh between the producer
and the consumer.
There is no proxy.
The performance is
exactly the same.
And whenever you want, you
can delete the peering.
It's a bidirectional peering.
Even a singular, say, a
producer decided that, like, I
don't want peering
with you anymore,
you can cut the peering.
All the routing will go away.
It's a magic of routing,
distributed routing,
between the two networks.
And once a peering
is established,
you can use the
actual load balancers.
A consumer can actually talk
to the internal load balancing
[? VIP ?] inside
the producer network
and get the services done.
And this is in all five.
If you're interested,
please talk to us.
We can whitelist you.
The fourth feature in today--
there's a lot of features.
Fourth new feature, we
are very happy to offer--
egress firewalls.
So far, for a couple
of years, we offered--
[APPLAUSE]
--distributor firewalls--
thank you very much.
Distributor firewalls, VM
to VM and internet to VM,
ingress side.
Exact same thing we
offer VM to internet.
Same connection tracking
firewall, stateful.
Everything is
stateful firewalls.
We'll do connection tracking.
We'll do priority, deny and
permit in all directions.
No choke points.
Everything is distributor
routing, distributor firewalls.
Just to complete the
picture, GKE firewalls.
Another big request for the
[? GCE ?] firewalls is, hey,
I have only limited quota, 200
firewall rules I can configure.
Hey, Subbaiah, can you increase
the quota for more firewall
rules?
I have microsegmentation
going on.
We are working on it.
But if you're running
in containers,
you have another option.
The rich ecosystem of,
actually, open source community
there in GKE, you can go
and create a GKE policy.
It'll create a lot
of firewall rules
in iptables in your hosts.
You can use that.
And you can use,
actually, pretty well.
All the microsegmentation,
whatever you have in GKE,
you can use that to create,
behind the scenes iptables.
And we are working on
all of these things.
Another feature called private
access to Google Services.
As you see, machine learning
services, analytics services,
storage services,
so many services
we offer in a
different namespace,
like highly available
things than from the VMs.
But if we have a VPC with a
private IP address, RFC 1918 IP
space, you can access,
privately, those
services without having
any public IP address.
You can just go to
the subnetwork's UI,
click, and say, Enable,
power private access
to Google services-- boom.
That's it.
Done.
Just one click away.
Yesterday there was a demo
of this in one of the talks.
But that means any client from
the internet cannot access
their private VMs.
But if they want to access
the Google Services,
they have to go through
these Google APIs.
They need to have permission
to go through the Google APIs.
More of the security stuff.
It's all documented in our
GCP nicely in our web pages.
If you have VMs with
private IP addresses
and with our private--
with external addresses
and without external
addresses, we
have a couple of
security things.
We do offer Bastion host
support, all GCloud commands.
We have SOCKS proxying
for SSH port tunneling.
We have port forwarding
with SSH tunneling.
We have HTTPS with SSL
keys and without IP
external IP addresses.
We have NAT.
You can actually easily set
up your own NAT gateways.
All of these things,
four new features
we are offering in
networking, is available,
because of our cloud
networking distributor stack.
Basically, it's a
software-defined stack.
We call it Andromeda stack.
And there is a talk
happened yesterday.
You can watch it on YouTube.
We talked more about this.
To recap, just remember,
so we have these features
available for you--
egress firewalls, VPC sharing,
VPC peering, multi-NIC support.
With that, thank you very much.
Give it to Jigar from
Palo Alto Networks.
Show you the demo.
JIGAR SHAH: OK,
thank you, Subbaiah.
So my name is Jigar Shah.
I'm a product manager
at Palo Alto Networks.
I focus on public clouds.
So before I begin, I
would like to call out
that we're going to
show you a demo that
shows how we're going to provide
security in the Google Cloud
environment.
So there's a few set
of new features coming.
I'm not going to talk
about all of them,
just the specific things that
I'm going to show in this demo.
So before I go ahead,
a quick show of hands.
How many of you are network
admins or networking experts?
OK, fair number.
How about security guys?
OK.
I see some of them, the same
hands, which just makes sense.
And how about application or
other infrastructure folks?
OK.
So a good mix.
So this is sort of the
DevOps kind of world.
So public cloud operates
in a shared security model,
right? [? Urs ?] mentioned
a whole bunch of security
features in the morning.
Subbaiah mentioned a
lot of others, right?
So Google takes care of
security off the cloud.
But once a packet hits
your VPC or your network,
it's your responsibility to
protect that environment.
And there's a lot of great
tools they give you, right?
IAM rules, Google
Cloud firewall,
ACL, all those components.
But even beyond
that, once the packet
comes in, if there's
malware, there's no malware,
how do you look for that?
How do you protect against that?
So if you look at a Google Cloud
firewall, GCP firewall rules,
they pretty much look like this.
You can do controls at a five
[? topo ?] level-- source,
destination, port, protocol.
That's what you do.
So a typical transaction
would probably look like this.
This is the information
you see in the wire.
And it's a 344-kilobyte
transaction.
What if you could actually
look at more things
and make decisions
based on that?
So for example, oh,
it's not just 443,
it's actually HTTP
running on SSL.
And oh, this is
the specific user
and they belong to this
specific LDAP or AD user group.
And the destination
traffic is actually
geomapped to some user in Canada
or some destination in Canada.
What are the
attributes of that URL?
Is it a known command
control server or is it
just regular commercial
proper, benign server?
So there's all these other
additional intelligence
and metadata that can be
valuable in making a decision.
And in addition, just
because it's HTTP
doesn't mean anything anymore.
Everything is pretty much HTTP,
especially in the public cloud.
So, for example, if it's a
slide-sharing application, oh,
and it's got a payload off a PDF
file being transferred, right?
So those are important
attributes you want to look at.
Now, this is a benign
example of a flow,
let's say, going out from
a Google Cloud VM outbound.
Everything should
allow it, right?
It looks all perfect and benign.
But your firewall rules,
if this was actually
some real malware, like
a pre-executable that's
going through and
it's got malware,
you wouldn't know how to
control for it, in effect.
So if you look at an
attack lifecycle--
and this is one
manifestation; this is
a famous framework, in effect--
that typical exploit vectors
happen from either an insider
making some mistakes
or a malicious insider
or an outsider doing a breach.
So essentially, I like to
call it a north-south problem.
Somebody's breached in.
And then they want to branch off
and find out where next to go,
whether it's on-prem
or in the cloud.
And a lot of use cases
are hybrid, right?
You may have a big application
in the public cloud,
but there might be some
connection going back
to on-prem.
That becomes a really important
vector for the attack.
And the most common things
we see in terms of attacks
is, you know, people
want to steal your data.
That's the most
valuable asset you've
got, whether it's user
information, credit card
information, so on.
Now we are also starting to
see botnets also starting up.
If you look at the
data out there,
a number of public VMs,
when they get hijacked,
because mostly of poor
security practices,
they become really good botnets.
Because the bandwidth
available from a public cloud
environment's
enormously well capable.
It's very powerful networking.
So botnets have a very easy
way of spreading around.
And then less
often, we also start
to see that you've got really
good compute resources.
Let's run a bitcoin
mining operation.
It's really cheap compute.
As long as you get it,
it's free money, right?
So to prevent this, these
type of attacks, what you need
is complete visibility in
the enterprise network.
And in the cloud, in the
mobile, you need visibility.
What you can't see, you
can't really protect.
The next element is
reducing the attack surface.
So you're obviously
trying to narrow
that if it's a web location,
you may set up GCP firewall
rules to say open 40 and 443.
You do all the basic things
to say reduce attack surface.
If you know the
applications, you
can identify applications, put
controls based on applications
specifically.
And then comes the more
intelligent part to say,
is there actually malware?
Are these all known
CV and vulnerabilities
that are out there known?
Let's block them
right out of the box.
So the attacker should not
have an opportunity to say,
I'm going to go hack this.
Obviously, this requires that
all your systems are patched
correctly as often as
possible, so you're protected
against known vulnerabilities.
But what about unknown
vulnerabilities, right?
So these can be zero day attacks
or brand new attacks that
are not zero day caliber, but
people don't know about them.
How quickly can we
fix them, right?
Because the goal is to do
prevention and not really say,
OK, we found a problem.
Let's go fix it.
Throw in the incident
response team.
Spend lots of hours and
dollars on consulting people
coming doing IR and forensics.
You want to put up as much
protection as possible,
so you're not spending
money later on.
So to do this requires a lot
of capabilities under the hood.
So I'm not going to go
through these things,
because there's a lot
of detail in there.
But I'll pick a quick
specific example.
Let's say there's a
malware that is spreading.
It's a known malware.
What application
is it attacking?
Typically, a malware
is looking for exploits
in specific applications
or specific binaries.
Often that application
is going to be encrypted.
Pretty much 70% or
more of applications
are getting encrypted.
So you want a
solution that's going
to be able to even do SSL
decrypt when it's necessary.
And then you want
to have coverage,
like I was saying,
across the board.
So obviously, cloud visibility
is really important.
And then for those unknown
things, like I said,
there's a lot of machine
learning, dynamic analysis,
static analysis techniques.
So I'm not going into details.
But those are
typical capabilities
you'd need to sort of
provide that protection.
So let me switch
gears and say how
does this manifest in the
Google Cloud environment?
So the idea is that to bring a
next generation firewall, which
has all these capabilities.
We needed a
multi-NIC capability.
So Google has that
capability, so that you
can create clean segmentation.
So you have their
management network,
you may have a
public-facing side
network for internet-based
focused services,
and then you may have
multiple private networks,
where you're running
your applications
in different tiers.
So the firewall can now
connect across all of them
and provide that north-south
and east-west security
between application tiers.
Obviously, this is
a single firewall.
I wouldn't recommend anybody
to put this up right now,
because it's a single
point of failure.
What you need is, obviously,
a scale-out architecture,
that you have load
balancers that
are front-ending your service.
You put security behind it.
And then you put your
application tier behind it.
Now, obviously, this is a
static picture, so to speak,
and the cloud is all
about elasticity.
So as demand for
your services grow,
your web tier on your
front end tier is growing,
other things behind
it are automatically
scaling, the firewall and
the security services also
need to scale behind it.
And this has to be
very seamless to you,
which means you need
bootstrapping and automation.
But it has to be transparent.
You can't be spending time
to say, oh, stuff scaled up,
I need to do something.
So I showed internet-facing
scale-out architecture.
There's obviously other use
cases, primarily, hybrid cloud,
meaning on-prem connecting into
the Google Cloud environment.
There's very specific
security scenarios
that need to be covered there.
There's segmentation,
like I said,
between application tiers.
And then between
different projects,
like Subbaiah was
showing, when you have,
let's say, department 1
talking to department 2,
where department
1 or application 1
has a higher trust level.
The other one has a
lower trust level.
If you were going to
do full VPC peering,
do you really want
that full mesh?
If it's between two networks
of equal trust, it makes sense.
If there are networks
of different trust,
you probably want to do
deeper inspection to say,
if I have this
partner connecting in,
I want to let them access
to only these things.
I'm going to make sure
that if they are hacked,
I don't get hacked.
And then the
internet-facing scale
out perimeter
capability I showed
with the scale-out story.
So I'll give you
a demo, so that it
becomes a little bit
more apparent of what
we're bringing to the table.
So I'm going to switch
over to the demo.
So here you see typical
Google Cloud networks set up
in a project.
I've got four networks set up.
So I've got the
database network.
I've got a management network
for the management traffic,
an internet-facing public trough
network, and a web network.
And on the Compute side,
I've got three VMs only,
very simple demo in that sense.
So this is the firewall, the
next generation firewall.
It's a four NIC setup, like
I showed in the diagram.
And there's a database
network and a web server
network where the database
and the web server are living.
The web server's
running a simple Apache
server and a WordPress server.
And the WordPress
server has content
that's living in the database.
So the demo's intention
is to sort of show you
that north-south and that
east-west protection.
So this is my web server.
This is the Apache.
It's really simple.
I load it up.
And it's got the
typical content.
And as usual, obligatory,
you got to put a cat video.
So there's HTTP
content coming in.
So if I go ahead and
look into the firewall,
I mean, it's kind of fun.
You put up, let's say, a
good monitoring solution,
like us, that's just an
application visibility service,
and you should see the number
of people doing port scans.
And then once you
see a open port,
they start trying to
poke through the holes.
So this is the interface
for the firewall.
So let me first walk
you through the policies
I've configured in this demo.
So the first thing you see is
the left side is the source
side and the right side
is the destination.
So I see Inbound Web going
from the public internet side
to the web tier.
And I said Allow Web Browsing.
So I'm not saying allow anything
else, just web browsing.
We're going to look
at the packets to say,
are these actual HTTP packets,
HTTP transaction, right?
Nothing else should be allowed.
And then web to DB, web
area going to database.
So what I'm saying is Allow
Traffic Only, actually
specifically MySQL, because
by starting and identifying
the patterns, we know
what MySQL looks like.
So we're saying, OK,
allow MySQL only.
And the third thing
I'm doing is all
the Linux VMs, the web server,
the database, they probably
need to do updates.
So I'm going from
web and database
to the public internet.
And I'm saying only allow
updates for apt-get or yum
updates.
I could even further
lock it down and say,
you can only go to Canonical
to get your updates
or whatever your repo is.
So you can do some very
specific lockdowns.
And then I've got
the special exception
to say allow SSH only for
my corporate IP address.
And my corporate IP
addresses are loaded here.
So that way I can do
specific management even
over the open internet, but
still locked down to my IPs.
So if I go to the
Monitor tab, this
is showing the traffic
logs of our firewall.
So if I do a refresh,
you can see that there's
a lot of traffic coming in.
OK, shouldn't have
hit Refresh there.
You can see there's a
lot of traffic coming in
from the open internet.
And you can see a lot
of people are trying
to connect to my public IP.
By the way, this public IP
has no real application.
But somebody's sitting there
and just constantly scanning,
looking for the stuff.
You can see, obviously,
there's traffic
coming from [? Mosconi, ?]
which is the page I just loaded.
So that was the Apache server.
And we obviously identified.
And sometimes we will
not get enough packets
to say what kind of traffic it
is, so we're saying incomplete.
But let's say, I go back
and reload the page.
And then just got
to refresh the--
oops.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] scroll across.
Let me maximize
this, so it's easier.
So if I refresh the
data, you're going
to see there's traffic for
web browsing coming in.
So now, similarly, if I have a
WordPress on that same server,
so I reload the WordPress pages.
So this obviously is
going to go transaction
with the WordPress server.
That's going to reach
into the SQL database.
So if I go back and look at
the logs, what I'm seeing
is traffic coming in from the
public internet to the web
zone, going to its
web browsing traffic.
And then what you
would expect to see
is further down
is the web server
is reaching into the
database and SQL transactions
are happening there.
So I'm doing a very
specific lockdown
to say these are the only
flows you should allow based
on the application patterns.
Now, in addition, you can
obviously enable deeper IDS/IDS
things, so that if your
web server's compromised
and somebody's trying to do a
SQL injection or another attack
on the database, we're
able to provide that.
Now, the more interesting
news, obviously,
is also the exfiltration part.
So you can make sure that
somebody cannot do mass FTP
transfers or mass HTTP
transfers or big file outflows.
So those are the things that
we intend to sort of provide
in terms of protection.
So there's a demo at our
booth in the expo floor
if you want to take a look.
And there's more
information on the website.
So that's all I
had for the demo.
If you've got questions, I
can take them afterwards.
So after that, I'll hand
it over to Prajakta.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Which
one should I use?
Which laptop?
So hi, folks.
I'm Prajakta.
I'm a product manager
in Cloud Networking.
So how many of you stay
up at night thinking
about DDoS attacks?
Nobody?
Your networks are super secure.
Yeah.
And I'm sure they're on
Google Cloud, which is
why you don't stay up at night.
So that's great.
So most of you know
about DDoS attacks.
I'm not going to go into them.
Most of you know that
they're also classified
into three categories--
network, connection,
application.
Each of these attacks has
interesting characters.
So the layer 3 will try to
just overwhelm your network
and consume all the bandwidth.
With layer 4, basically,
they're trying
to exhaust any type of
component in your network that
has a state table.
And the layer 7 ones try to
exploit the characteristics
of your application.
Now, here is the
interesting bit.
Most of you may
not know, but when
you're actually on
Google Cloud Platform
and you're using Google
Cloud load balancing or CDN,
your deployments have
inbuilt or rather implicit
DDoS protection for
layer 3 and layer 4.
And you can, of course,
complement this with offerings
from our other partners and
our third party providers.
So let's take a closer look.
You have your VM.
What may not be obvious is that
you actually have throttles
per VM at 10 Gbps, which means
even if you get attacked,
there is going to be no impact
to your standing as a customer.
Next, if you actually deploy
Google Cloud load balancing--
and you know that it
comes in various flavors,
such as HTTP/HTTPS
load balancing,
SSL proxy, PCP proxy.
So if you implement
that, you do actually
get protection against
layer 3 and layer 4 attacks,
so attacks such as SYN floods,
IP fragment floods, and so on.
And in fact, HTTP/HTTPS
load balancing
not only protects you
against these attacks,
but other attacks, such
as Slowloris and so on.
And then, of course, you can
use Cloud CDN along with that.
So you can serve
your legitimate users
from the edge of our network.
This one just recaps
what I spoke about.
So I'm actually going
to skip this slide.
So I wanted to tell you
an interesting story.
How many of you have
heard of Brian Krebs?
Great.
So for those of you who
did not raise your hand,
he's an investigative
journalist.
He actually exposes criminals.
He has a website out
called KrebsOnSecurity.com.
As you can imagine,
when he did that,
the criminals came after him.
They started
DDoSing his website.
And the attacks
got so huge that he
was asked by his previous
provider to move,
because it would have impacted
their other customers.
He came to Google for help.
And so we hosted him for free
on Google Cloud infrastructure
under a project we
call Project Shield.
So it is to protect
the freedom of speech
and also to protect
journalists and then
other entities that participate
in elections and so on.
Now, here is an interesting
set of events that were
told to me by our DDoS expert.
This is how it actually rolled
out after KrebsOnSecurity came
to the Google Cloud Platform.
So when he came back up, it was
hit with 130 million packets
per second of SYN floods.
And for those of you who are
familiar with Mirai botnets,
this was precisely that.
It also received additional
60 million packets
per seconds of resets.
The attack was huge,
but there was no impact.
And this is because the
SYN floods were handled
by Google infrastructure.
Now, a minute later,
the attack shifted.
It was 250 gig queries
per second attack
from about 145K Mirai IPs.
And this is a good
example of how
attackers try random stuff until
they find something that works.
An hour later, there
were a few more attacks,
but there was no
impact to his site.
The Google infrastructure
continued to shield it.
At this point, there
was a bit of a respite.
So the attacks
stopped for some time.
Next morning, Brian was happy.
He posted this post, called "The
Democratization of Censorship"
and how Google infrastructure
was hosting and protecting
his website.
Four hours after
this blog post, he
was hit with 450-gig queries
per second of HTTP floods
from 175K Mirai IPs.
And this went on and on and on.
There were dozens of attacks.
But it also gave our team
a really great opportunity
to validate Google's defenses.
So why am I telling
you this story?
First, the happy ending.
KrebsOnSecurity.com continues to
run unimpacted on Google Cloud.
But I told you
about this incident,
because this same infrastructure
protects your deployments
in the Google Cloud.
This happens when you enable
either Google Cloud load
balancing or Google Cloud
load balancing with Cloud CDN.
And you can
definitely complement
this with services and appliance
from our third party providers.
And so to talk more
about that, I'd
like to invite Michelle, the
co-founder of Cloudflare.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHELLE ZETLYN:
Hello, everybody.
I'm Michelle Zetlyn.
I'm one of the
founders of Cloudflare.
And I'm really excited
to be here today
to talk about security and
some of the toughest challenges
that we're dealing with.
Before I do that, though,
I just want tell you
a little bit about Cloudflare,
because many of you
may not know about us.
At some level, we're a little
bit of a boring infrastructure
company, that when
we do our jobs right,
we're behind the scenes.
But let me tell you
a little bit more.
So our mission as a
company is to help
build a better internet.
We run one of the largest
networks in the world.
So we have over 100 points
of presence around the world.
That means in some not
so exotic locations,
like San Jose, California,
or Los Angeles, to over 20
across mainland China, as
well as points of presence
across Africa and Latin America.
We're really close
to where people
are consuming the internet.
We're really close
to the eyeballs.
Our network does about 10
million requests per second.
And what that means is about
10% of all internet requests
touches Cloudflare's network.
So if you've been online this
morning surfing the internet,
it's likely that you've been
interacting with Cloudflare's
network behind the scenes.
We have a lot of
different customers.
Over six million
customers use Cloudflare,
from large businesses
to small businesses
to bloggers around the world.
And they come to us,
because we're really
helping solve a lot of the
internet's tough challenges,
including performance, security,
reliability, and insights.
All of these things that
used to be very hard
and you used to buy a
lot of hardware boxes for
are moving out to the
edge as a service,
and we do all that on
behalf of our customers.
Today I want to dig
into a little bit more
on the security side.
Because we see 10 million
requests per second,
we get a lot of
insights into what's
going on the security
landscape and wanted to share
some of those with you today.
And so Prajakta was
talking about DDoS attacks.
So this is the size
of DDoS attacks
and how they're on the rise.
In the last few
years, there has been
a huge acceleration to which
the size of the attacks are.
As a business, as
a network operator,
it's really scary to have
to think, oh, my god,
the DDoS attacks are now up
to 300 gigabits per second.
Before, 50 gigs per second
used to be considered big.
And now every day at
Cloudflare, our customers
are seeing routinely 300 and
400-gigabit per second attacks.
And then back in November,
OVH, a large network provider
in Europe, talked about
seeing an attack as
large as a terabit per second.
This is not going away.
So DDoS attacks are
definitely getting bigger.
Part of this is because
of the Internet of Things
that are coming online.
Cameras, refrigerators,
cars, everything
is getting connected
to the internet.
This is not going away.
And so what the experts
say is, oh, my god,
as Internet of
Things come online,
there are going to
be more security
vulnerabilities and threats.
And that is true.
And so as a business,
you need to figure out,
how am I going to deal
with these sorts of things?
Because this is absolutely true.
And the [? Mirai ?]
botnet was a bunch
of cameras that were
enabled that caused
that attack against
many customers,
including Brian Krebs.
The third is-- the
size is one thing.
New devices is a new thing.
The third is that
the attacks are
getting more complex against
the application layer.
They're really, really
targeted and clever.
And what that means is you
need more control as a business
owner to be able to stop
that, or shared intelligence,
so that whatever
solution you're using
learns faster, so that
if someone else sees
that same sort of
complicated attack
at the application layer,
you're protected against that.
So those are just some
trends that we're seeing.
So what does this
all boil up to?
And so we talked a lot about
what Google Cloud does for you.
So why would you
also need Cloudflare?
And so we have over 25,000 joint
customers with Google Cloud
that are also using Cloudflare.
And so what are they
getting in addition?
So think about us as
a security platform.
We crowdsource all
the threat data
from those 10 million
requests per second,
so that you are protected
from any sort of attack
that our other six million
customers are seeing.
So we crowdsource it.
It's an automatic learning.
And this is the first time where
all the good guys have banded
together to help
protect ourselves
against the botnets
and the bad guys.
And it's working.
We have presences in China.
So if you have internet users
coming to your site in China,
you can now be really
close to their eyeballs.
Again, we have over 20 points
of presence in mainland China.
Before, if you were thinking
about DDoS or firewalls
or encryption or DNS or load
balancing or rate limiting,
you might buy that from five or
six different security vendors.
Today, again, the
platform security
is you're getting that all
from Cloudflare as a service.
There's a lot of
new modern internet
standards that are pushing
forward to help keep us
into the future.
Whether it's TLS 1.3, which
is the new cryptography
standard, whether
it's HTTP/2, which
is much more of a
performance side, or DNSSEC,
Cloudflare makes that super
easy for all of our six million
customers to adapt in real time.
So we push that live, and you
automatically get access to it
without having to update
your origin server.
We also provide
flat rate pricing.
So if you get a DDoS attack,
there is no spike in pricing.
It's predictable.
It's the exact same thing month
to month because we know how
if you are under a DDoS attack,
how that already is a bad day.
We don't want to
make it a worse day.
Google Cloud is an
amazing service.
And many of you are already
customers or thinking
about joining them.
But you also may
have on-premise.
You also may be using a
second cloud provider.
Or who knows?
You might also be using GoDaddy.
Cloudflare sits at
the network layer.
So we work with regardless what
you're using for store compute.
And you can make
sure that anything
that you're running
in those environments
have the performance, security,
reliability, and insights
that we offer.
And so a true partnership means
when you partner together, you
create value.
And Google and
Cloudflare has done that.
We both run large networks.
And what we've done is
we've interconnected
in 41 of those
locations, which means
that we pass the savings
onto the end customer.
So at the end of the day, if
you are a Google Cloud Compute
customer and a Cloudflare
customer, you're saving money.
And I just wanted to walk
through two examples,
case studies of how other
customers [? interconnect. ?]
So Discord is a voice and
text messaging service
for online computer games.
This company had explosive
growth last year.
They went from about 25,000
concurrent users to 2.4 million
in a year.
That's 9,000% growth.
Just think about that.
Think about that if you had
to manage that in your shoes.
Their team was working
really, really hard.
So a couple of things
that were happening.
First, they used to
buy a lot of hardware,
a lot of on-premise hardware.
That's how they used to
manage their environment.
But what happened
is, it turns out
that a lot of folks, players
who are playing video games,
like to launch attacks
against each other.
And they had to deal with a lot
of different types of layer 3,
layer 4, layer 7 DDoS attacks.
And so they signed
up for Cloudflare.
And we helped get rid
of those automatically.
They moved their infrastructure
into Google Cloud.
And it helped them scale
much more quickly than what
they were doing before.
The end result is
when they looked
at what they were spending in
2015 versus what they spent
in 2016, together,
Cloudflare and Google
saved them over
$100,000 a month.
That's over $1
million a year, plus
they got this great performance
and security solution,
because they're really
close to all their visitors
around the world.
So that's example one.
Example two is a
company called Quizlet.
They're one of the top
100 Alexa ranked websites.
It helps students around
the world do homework.
Turns out there's
a lot of students
around the world that aren't
necessarily in North America.
They're everywhere.
So they have a lot of traffic
that's very, very global.
And so they came to
Cloudflare, because they
were having huge performance
issues and security issues.
And so because we had over
100 points of presence,
they immediately saw a huge
performance improvement
by coming onto Cloudflare
and with Google Cloud.
And what they saw, because
of our partnership,
that they see a 76% savings
in their bandwidth bill.
They saw their
bandwidth drop by 76%.
And this is by caching closer
to the internet surfers
and by offloading all the
traffic really, really, out
at the edge.
That translated into
a savings of about 15%
off of their bandwidth bill from
month to month on Google Cloud.
And so this is an
example of a partnership
that, again, I think any good
partnership means delivering
value to the end customer.
And we're really honored to be
working with the Google Cloud
team.
They're terrific in helping
solve some of the biggest
challenges on the internet.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And we
really value our partners
and our providers as well.
So I'm going to give
you guys a test--
guys and girls a test.
What did we talk about first?
So let's bring it all together
into a cloud networking
security blueprint.
The first thing that you
need to really worry about
is ensuring that your
VPC is safe and secure.
Subbaiah talked about
the variety of tools
that you have at your disposal.
So you've got VPC
topologies for isolation.
You've got
distributed firewalls.
You've got IAM.
And you can access any
of Google's own services,
such as machine
learning or BigQuery,
internally without
going to the internet.
This is something we
didn't talk about,
because there are a number
of interesting sessions,
but that is secure connectivity.
We do realize you have
deployments either on-prem
or another cloud.
And so we want to ensure
that you can connect
those to GCP very securely.
You've got direct peering,
carrier interconnect, VPNs,
and a new one that we
introduced in this GCP
next called private
interconnect.
Jigar spoke about using third
party virtual appliances.
One of the points I
did want to mention
is make sure that you scale
out your virtual appliances
using Google internal
load balancing,
because you don't want to
create new choke points
in your network.
Definitely look at our
Google global load balancer.
So this comes, as
I mentioned before,
in HTTP as load balancing,
SSL proxy, TCP proxy.
You get built in layer 3
and layer 4 DDoS protection
with this.
And you can also supplement
that with Cloud CDN.
And finally, Google's network.
This is a high-capacity,
high-performance network
that not only gives you global
connectivity and global reach,
but also protects
you against attacks,
including UDP-based attacks.
And then you can
finally complement
all of this with DDoS defense
from our third party provider.
So you just heard from
Michelle about DDoS defense
from Cloudflare.
And we have a bunch of
other partners or providers
that you can work with as well.
Actually, yes, I just want
you to actually take a minute
and look at this,
because this is actually
the networking blueprint that a
lot of our customers use today.
And this is how they
secure their workloads
on Google Cloud.
This is an interesting
quote from Evernote.
How many of you know that
Evernote recently migrated
to Google Cloud Platform?
Correct.
So they started
migrating roughly
around September of 2016.
And the interesting
comment that they made
is, we moved to
the Google Cloud,
because can not only
provide security
as good as what we have
on-prem, but we can actually
improve on it.
We can provide all
of these protections.
And we have this
expertise in Google
that we would not
have had on-prem.
And that is a huge endorsement.
And the way they did it is they
followed this cloud networking
blueprint.
So our goal today was
to share it with you.
We hope you make use of it.
And we hope it lets you
sleep peacefully at night.
So thank you, everyone.
And stay safe.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]